[Música]
bajo el mando del presidente de joe by
de eeuu ha dado un giro a su política
frente a cuba y venezuela en el caso
cubano revivió las actividades
consulares enfocado en la reunificación
familiar con las emisiones de no menos
de 20.000 visados para la migración
legal de cubanos además de la
reactivación de vuelos directos a varias
ciudades de la isla la suspensión del
límite de 1000 dólares por trimestre al
hacer remesas y del lado venezolano se
relajaron algunas sanciones dando
permiso a la multinacional chevron para
negociar con el país caribeño futuras
actividades petroleras tras los castigos
que en 2019 buscaron apoyar a juan
guaidó y a su llamado gobierno interino
vamos así con nuestro primero invitado
del día michele shifter profesora de la
universidad de georgetown y ex
presidente del diálogo interamericano un
centro de pensamiento de los asuntos del
hemisferio muchas gracias a usted y
cuesta creer que los últimos movimientos
de eeuu son casualidades precisamente en
la antesala de la cumbre de las américas
bajaron las medidas contra cuba y las
sanciones contra venezuela porque este
cambio en la política exterior del
gobierno estadounidense usted cree que
está cediendo a la casablanca a la
presión de los países que amenazan con
no existir
bueno muchas gracias y buenos días
pero yo creo que la cumbre es sin duda
es un es un
motivo por el cambio de la política ante
frente a cuba y frente a venezuela
también porque como usted dijo varios
países empezando con méxico que es lo
más significativo
amenazado no existía en la cumbre
y es la es el gran show de bailén para
mostrar su compromiso américa latina y
si no aparecen los líderes invitados
esto sería digamos embarazoso para para
él entonces él está yo creo que hay que
interpretar estos cambios en ese
contexto esperan con esperanza que esto
se va a convencer los líderes que
amenazaron no existir a participar en la
cumbre
empezando la primera el 6 de enero en
los ángeles pero otros dos temas también
que son relevantes para entender esos
cambios uno es la crisis migratorio en
estados unidos
y sobre todo con los cubanos yo creo que
este año el año pasado llegó como
150.000 cubanos de eeuu y estos en
cambios de política están buscar un poco
ordenar el flujo de migrantes
a cuba a eeuu y también con el permiso
de enviar remesas ojala bajar la presión
en cuba para emigrar a eeuu yo creo que
es un tema político muy importante
antes de las elecciones de medio término
en
noviembre en eeuu entonces yo creo que
hay que entender ese factor con respecto
a cuba con respecto a venezuela también
hay que entender que la crisis en
ucrania la tragedia ucrania y colapso
del mercado internacional del petróleo
obviamente ha puesto mucha presión para
la administración para buscar otros
fuentes de petróleo eeuu que lo que
usted mencionó
a la licencia un poco yo creo que tienen
que entender y explicarlo con relación a
ese tema del petróleo bueno y sigamos
hablando entonces de venezuela que
significa que se puedan volver a sentar
a la mesa a chevron y pedevesa porque ha
sido muy claro el gobierno de eeuu en
que este relajamiento de las sanciones
no implica que van a llegar más ingresos
para el gobierno de nicolás maduro y
tampoco implica que pueden hacer
negocios directamente
bueno así yo creo que la administración
ha sido bastante claro que estos son las
secciones económicas
no han cambiado lo que esto es es una
medida para flexibilizar para dar
algunos permisos licencias al a chevron
para el suministro de algún petróleo de
venezuela a las refinerías en el golfo
que antes estaba recibiendo petróleo
desde rusia entonces yo creo que esto es
algo
que no implica el levantamiento de
sanciones
con respecto a venezuela para eso creo
que van a insistir siempre que hay
concesiones por parte de maduro para
tener elecciones libres
en 2024 presidenciales y esto obviamente
no ha pasado entonces eso depende de ese
negociaciones que va a ocurrir en méxico
que también eeuu interesa entonces esto
es algo
qué es algo menor pero nos dice que
levantar las acciones contra la contra
de venezuela
bueno
finalmente manteniéndonos un poco en el
tema de la cumbre de las américas que
engloba un poco la política
estadounidense hacia estos dos países se
han mencionado múltiples veces la carta
democrática interamericana como razón
para no invitar precisamente a cuba a
venezuela y también a nicaragua a la
cumbre que se realizará en los ángeles
háblenos un poco de este documento en
qué consiste
bueno la carta interamericana de
democracia fue aprobado en
2002 2001 en lima perú y firmado por
todos los miembros de la hoya y
básicamente
sostienen que
que
ósea da una primera vez en la olla a la
historia del down es definición muy
clara la democracia que consiste en
gobiernos elegidos
abiertamente libremente y si no cumplen
con ese requisito
aunque básicamente no son democracias
entonces eeuu está señalando utilizando
ese documento esa carta democrática para
mostrar que los otros países no cumplen
son dictadores no cumplen los requisitos
básicos de elecciones libres y por lo
tanto no debe estar invitados a la
cumbre de las américas porque la
cantidad práctica es un instrumento muy
importante de todo lo hemisferio es el
argumento a la administración pero lado
los otros dicen que bueno como fue
invitado y parte raúl castro participó
en la cumbre en panamá en 2015 y también
fue invitado a la última cumbre en lima
perú en 2010 18 donde cuba participó
entonces como posible que había
participado y ahora después de la carta
democracia en este caso ahora no están
participando es un poco la controlarse
un poco el debate que que tiene pero
creo que eeuu tienen alguna razón y
alguna lógica señalar que efectivamente
esos tres países que no cumplen a pesar
de todos los problemas de democracia en
otros países brasil méxico y colombia y
todos los países esos tres países son
básicamente dictadores que no hay
elecciones libres entonces eso es el
argumento que están usando pero en este
momento solamente para terminar yo creo
que están el último noticia que está
buscando está desde una manera de una de
un acuerdo donde se invitan
representantes de de cuba por ejemplo
pero no
el día en el que se presidente de cuba
entonces una una digamos una forma la
intermedia